kim kardashian comes clean about that
whole disneyland photoshop debacle yep
but fires back with receipts after
people accuse her of a photoshop fail in
this snap with boyfriend pete davidson
oh my god all this while a source tells
et the 41 year old skims founder is head
over heels for the 28 year old comedian
and she can't wait for fans to watch
their love story unfold on her family's
new hulu series we'll just have to wait
and see
right let's get you up to speed
back in december kim shared this snap of
what appears to be her daughter chicago
and chloe's daughter true at disneyland
but the kkw beauty founder's followers
were suspicious of true's placement in
the pic saying it was giving off major
copy and paste vibes and earlier this
month coco admitted fans were right when
she took her little girl to the theme
park for her fourth birthday posting
this clip to her insta story this is
true's first time to disneyland
yep you heard that right first time to
disneyland this is true's first time to
disneyland the 37 year old's good
american founder later confirmed it
herself tweeting in part quote
welp i picked this one up anyways let's
focus on something else genuinely i
cannot believe it well on wednesday kim
fessed up too writing on her insta story
that the whole thing needs serious
explaining so that's what she did kim
says she loves an instagram aesthetic
and since her grid is currently a solid
mix of pink and blue she wanted to post
this pic of chicago in pink with kylie's
daughter stormi at disneyland but kylie
she wasn't feeling it and while the
reality star said she respected her
little sister's wishes kim still wanted
that pick for the gram quote you know
how much a good aesthetic means to my
soul and i will be damned if kylie will
ruin that for me and mess up my grid so
kim swapped stormy for true and didn't
think it would be that big of a deal why
not and while kim was on the topic of
coming clean she insists she has nothing
to hide when it comes to speculation
that she tweaked pete's nose and jawline
in this cuddled up pic
and to prove it she shared the live
version of the snap writing how do you
photoshop a live photo asking for a
friend
what do you love about him what's your
favorite thing about him
um
he's just super genuine yeah and it's
just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing
that's the goal is finding someone to do
nothing with it's the best because you
can do everything with totally but it's
crazy to be distracted with people you
can be with anyone
distracted but you can't be with anyone
and do nothing and speaking of pete a
source tells e.t the two are in a great
place in their relationship adding that
she is so happy her family loves him too
and she feels light and fun when she's
around him which echoes what the famous
fam told et earlier this month i love
that he's kind
and really really thoughtful he's the
most thoughtful person
and i love yeah and i love the chemistry
that kim and him have together it's
really sweet i thought you said the
chemistry i was like okay chemistry
chemistry
that can be a new fragrance
[Music]